ça marche pas ça marche pas ce format
sur TF1 et ce format partout c'est pas
un format qui marche en France c'est
catastrophique côté audience sachez-le
je vous le dis 10.2 le premier jour 15.8
le deuxième jour avec le match de
l'équipe de France avant et sachez que
TF1 avait vendu à la Régie la régie je
vous explique un truc c'est à dire quand
vous faites une émission vous dites
voilà cette émission va faire tant et
ils vendent surtout les moins de 50 ans
ce qu'on appelle la ménagère qui est
voilà c'est la ménagère c'est la
responsable des achats donc c'est celle
qui va le plus acheter en voyant les
pubs sachez qu'ils ont vendu 35
ménagères ça veut dire 35 ménagères ça
veut dire un chiffre de 35 ménagers
aujourd'hui ils sont entre en deux
émissions et je crois qu'ils sont à 20
ménagères en plus avec le 24 d'hier qui
est avec l'équipe de France avant donc
voilà ils vont perdre pas mal d'argent
sachez que les missions coûte très cher
elle coûte on m'a dit pour l'instant on
n'a pas encore les chiffres exacts mais
aux environs de 350 400 000 euros ce qui
est énorme la soirée donc c'est énorme
et c'est vrai que sur les réseaux il y
avait pas mal de commentaires négatifs
tout le monde attendait ça donc voilà à
part voilà deux trois personnes qui ont
bien aimé si ils disent que c'est du
vieux revue et ça va peut-être moi je
voudrais faire un comparatif avec un
lait chaud je vous jure que c'est vrai
que j'avais beaucoup plus aimé c'était
et vous alors vous allez dire ah ouais
bizarre qui dit ça parce que moi je dis
toujours la vérité je vous dis
franchement je j'avais j'avais bien aimé
moi le lait chaud avec Arthur j'ai
préféré le lait chaud avec Arthur Ce
soir avec Arthur sur Comédie il avait
quatre francs six sous pour le produire
il avait pas de 400000 euros et c'était
100 fois plus d'archanges je suis désolé
les mecs du coup on vous a fait une
petite comparaison entre les deux comme
ça vous savez vous voyez que bien je
suis sur honnête rien que sur le
générique de l'émission il décidait de
pas mettre un euro alors qu'ils sont sur
TF1
alors que là-bas tu avais un peu de
musique une ouverture de rideau et voilà
là c'était ça regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc voilà donc ça ça coûte 400000 les
mecs je sais pas où est l'argent mais
bon j'aimerais bien aimer produire cette
émission chez Arthur sur la chaîne
Comédie chaîne qui je le rappelle à deux
fois moins de budget que TV Breizh
c'est vrai regardez le générique
regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors les séries
le problème aussi qu'il y a dans
l'émission d'Alain Chabat c'est que
l'émission n'est pas en direct donc ils
en ont tourné en batterie 10 et donc ils
peuvent pas parler d'actualité donc
c'est dramatique et c'est vrai que les
chiffres sont dramatiques sachez le joli
vous pouvez boire les communiquer
tousser un drame les chiffres on va pas
se mentir Guillaume sur les ménagères
comme vous l'avez dit ils ont vendu 35 %
et là ils ont une équipe de France hier
ils n'auront plus jamais l'équipe de
France donc c'est grave avant eux
il y a un sketch du début d'émission
hier il y avait Pierre Richard que
j'adore Chalain ça va voilà moi j'adore
la chef tout ça moi c'est vrai que c'est
tu connais Pierre Richard je suis pierre
voilà moi j'adore alors je veux bien
mission des stars et des noms mais il
faut un petit peu d'écriture et c'est
vrai que là j'ai l'impression que les
auteurs ils étaient à aquaboulevards
je vais prendre quelques questions dans
le public monsieur comment comment vous
appelez-vous Monsieur Pierre Richard
quel est votre question pierre
est-ce que vous comptez inviter des
animaux atypiques
comme comme quoi par exemple une montre
religieuse athée
un manchot maladroit c'est bien non
alors non tout ça n'est pas prévu
j'adore les animaux aussi et j'aurai
adoré vous faire plaisir mais non je
suis désolé pierre
c'est une personne sympa à la droite
dans peu de gens voilà on se demande ce
que ça fout sur TF1 en fait
la programmation elle est tout sauf
populaire il y a quelques grosses stars
mais aussi des artistes qui sont mais
c'est vrai il y a pas de souci je suis
désolé Orelsan aujourd'hui
c'est très dur de faire un lait chaud
voilà on passe qui marche c'est la star
acade c'est camping paradisiers c'est
des émissions populaires ça coûte une
blinde on se dit pourquoi ils ont mis ça
à l'antenne pourquoi parce qu'ils ont un
gros deal avec des Burger Quiz ils les
ont liquidés avec ce lait chaud mais ça
n'a rien à faire là en plus au
quotidienne ça n'a aucun sens regardez
je vais vous montrer comme ça je fais un
comparatif ces deux animateurs de TF1
enfin Arthur est un animateur Alain
Chabat on voit dans cette émission que
ça n'est pas un animateur et
qu'animateur je vous jure ça reste un
métier alors un shabbat il est
incroyable c'est un acteur formidable
c'est un réalisateur formidable c'est un
auteur formidable mais animateur c'est
un métier et ça me fait plaisir de voir
ça et qu'on le veuille ou non vous le
savez voilà je dis Arthur est un
animateur Alain Chabat n'est pas un
animateur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la référence américaine déjà en Amérique
on pense à fait des millions de gens ça
fait 1 million 9 2 millions en Amérique
on est en Amérique en Amérique déjà
c'est déjà pas assez non événement et en
plus tout le monde a essayé depuis quoi
ça fait 15 20 ans tout le monde ait
voulu vous le faire il y a même notre
ami Jean-Pierre pourquoi
je vous le dis je trouve que le second
degré quand il est mal écrit ça ne
marche pas déjà en télé voilà non c'est
pas bien écrit c'est non c'est perché
intello
honnêtement ça c'est raté et puis alors
vous le dit et je finis juste pour ça la
France n'est pas un pays qui comment
qu'est-ce que vous avez dit c'est très
bien c'est pas un pays fait pour ce
genre de programme alors ils ont essayé
de faire un blind test regardez on a
comparé les jeux aussi regardez le jeu
le blind test made in Alain Chabat je
vous jure j'avais mal pour le mec moi le
pauvre qui faisait des claquettes le
pauvre ce sont des canines
je vous propose de jouer un petit jeu
c'est très simple c'est un jeu qui
s'appelle le top around c'est un blind
test de claquettes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
par contre j'aime bien le groupe moi
j'aime bien le groupe
le groupe le groupe est pas mal et
regardez le blind test avec Arthur
c'était carry habitants
alors je vous explique on va chanter
acapella attention
[Musique]
[Rires]
pour TF1 c'est un drame d'audience c'est
un drame d'image c'est un drame de tout
donc qu'est-ce qu'ils vont ils vont
perdre combien avec ces conneries là ils
vont perdre trop parce que le problème
Cyril c'est Alain Chabat je suis désolé
il est pas nul on dirait il est pas nul
mais là là c'est vrai que là je pense
que pour moi un moment et moi j'espère
vous me le direz quand c'est fini c'est
fini exactement
comme disait Charles Aznavour il faut
savoir quitter la table quand le
meilleur est des servi ça y est
franchement là même quand ils dansent
c'est tous les gars ça y est ça y est ça
y est il est très gentil très
sympathique mais c'est ça y est
excusez-moi
absolument pas drôle on ne rit j'ai
regardé tu n'as pas mis mais ne dis pas
que c'est pas drôle personne moi je vais
te dire un truc et je te jure une
émission bonne sur TF1 ça marche
toujours moi je vais te dire moi ma
boussole
je vais vous dire moi mes deux boussole
dans l'émission
les deux que je suis à chaque fois pour
savoir si ça va marcher ou pas il y en a
deux ici en cette émission qui
connaissent le public il y en a deux qui
connaissent qui qui savent ce que
veulent les gens et qui qui sont le
public et qui me ressemblent c'est Kelly
et pas là ce soir et Raymond je suis
désolé le reste bien sûr vous avez tous
vos sensibilités mais Raymond je sais
que quand Raymond ne regarde pas une
émission quand Kelly ne regarde pas
l'émission Kelly vedovine
je vais vous dire le lait chaud d'Alain
Chabat elle ne sait même pas de quoi on
lui parle elle ne ça n'existe pas pour
elle ici le public Raymond c'est le
public non c'est tu te sens c'est pas ça
c'est moi c'est mon public à moi c'est
parce que ça c'est notre public
peut-être ça manque de rythme moi
j'étais en attente sur Alain Chabat il
va me servir c'est les nuls ça va être
génial il va y avoir du riz et je
repensais et mon erreur ce que j'ai fait
moi j'ai repensé à ce soir avec Arthur
je me suis ici c'est la même chose on va
rigoler ça va être fou là il y a zéro
rythme il parle à des gens dans le
public qu'on connaît pas ils sont
acteurs apparemment il y a pas de sketch
c'est dedans non mais c'est non alors je
vous jure que il parle c'est très très
lent j'ai monté le public et je me suis
mis à regarder sur youtube Ce soir avec
Arthur avec Arthur et je me suis dit
Arthur bah ce serait Arthur c'est avec
Arthur Ce soir avec Arthur il fait
rentrer des Brésiliens quand les autres
chaînes vont en pub il y a Guigui la
moustache il y a des perso il y avait un
mail shabby avec Claudia
mais j'ai rigolé du vent très bien le
programme je pense qu'il doit être
content YouTube allez voir sur youtube
sur Youtube le Light d'Arthur et
regardez Alain Chabat c'est très lent et
je suis pas la cible
que vous ça vous a plu tiens c'est
important moi je trouve que c'est bien
écrit je trouve que vous êtes quand même
de mauvaise foi c'est bien écrit alors
on n'est pas de mauvaise fois on dit
c'est pas mieux mais c'est pas parce que
c'est pas parce qu'on ne pense pas comme
vous qu'il est de mauvaise foi
bibliothèque je veux pas que ce soit
bien écrit moi je me souviens
[Applaudissements]
tu as raison moi je trouve que le
principal problème en fait si ce
programme est sur Canal on a tous un
orgasme ce soir oh c'est génial
s'il te plaît non elle dit un orgasme ce
soir j'ai envie de le passer sur Canal
juste pour Daniel
franchement je trouve que l'erreur c'est
que ça n'a rien à [ __ ] sur TF1 je suis
d'accord aussi le problème sinon sur une
chaîne je pense que ça passerait très
très bien et je trouve que c'est quand
même il y a quand même une écriture qui
n'est peut-être pas une écriture
populaire mais c'est une écriture un peu
décalée un peu suspendu un peu perché un
peu absurde on reconnaît le ton de chat
là on a le droit de pas aimer parce que
c'est une énorme merde
aimez-vous l'émission oui à 53% de moins
48 % il était très bien il était très
bien oui mais les invités Orelsan était
très drôle c'est vrai mais il était
super mal aux pieds bien voilà non mais
genre du jardin aussi était bien mais
ils étaient tous mais aujourd'hui les
invités je suis pas d'accord non mais le
Jamel que j'ai vu hier c'est Jamel qui
me fait rigoler qui me fait le mec